يستقبل متحف الشريف للتراث في مدينه
الطائف غربيه السعوديه زواره يوميا وذلك
في نافذه تاريخيه تحاكي الطرق القديمه في
المنطقه المتحف تصل مساحته الى نحو 7000
متر مربع استغرق بناؤه واعداده نحو عشره
اعوام ليصبح من اكبر المتاحف في الطائف
ويتضمن قسما للسيارات القديمه وقسما لعرض
اسلحه معروفه منذ القدم في الطائف
بانواعها المتعدده فضلا عن قسم الحرف
اليدويه والفعاليات الاخرى
سعود الخلف ينضم الينا من احد متاحف
الطائف حياك الله سعود ناخذ معك جوله الله
الله الله الله الله الله من جدك هذه
بمناسبه يوم التاسيس ولا
شفت كيف يعني احنا قاعدين نلحق يوم
التاسيس الاحتفالات لا زالت مستمره في
كثير من مدن المملكه ومحافظاتها فقلنا يلا
خلينا نستغل هذه الفرصه ونتواجد في هذا
المتحف اللي يعتبر من اكبر المتاحف في
السعوديه ككل وكما ذكرت يعني يتجاوز
مساحته 7000 متر مربع وفي 25
قسم من الاقسام التي تعود فينا الى الزمن
الجميل في كثير من الامور خالد وخليناه في
البدايه اعطيك بس نبذه عن اللي انا لابسه
العقال المقصب ومعي المجمع ومعي البندق
المجمع والمجند المجند طبعا خاص بالرصاص
بالبنادق الناريه ولكن احنا حبينا نشكل
شوي حتى يعني نوصل الى اكبر جزء من
الجماليات في الزمن الجميل انا اقف الان
بجوار الخياط ومعي الاستاذ علي شريف صاحب
هذا المتحف اللي اخذ وقت كبير في تجهيزه
وراح ناخذ منه المعلومات التفصيليه ابو
حسن الله يعطيك العافيه على الشغل الجميل
هذا والزمن الجميل رجعتنا له احنا جنب
الخياط عطنا نبذه عن الخياط والملبوسات
اللي موجوده تبغى الخياط ولا تبغى المتحف
كله المتحف جمعه اخذ مني اكثر من ثلاثين
سنه تقريبا
تاسيس المتحف فوق 20 سنه يمر بخمسه وعشرين
قسم تقريبا احنا في السوق الشعبي هذا
السوق الشعبي هذا الخياط طبعا الخياط عندك
الثياب اللي بني سعد ميسان بالحارث ذوائح
الطائف زي الهدى الشفا بني مالك هذه
الثياب اللي هذه الثياب لقيت لها اقبال
كبير في يوم التاسيس اكيد وهذه يا ابو حسن
والله الناس اللي خيطتها تقول تسوى اكثر
من عشره الاف واكثر
احنا
سنه تقريبا الكاميرا الثابته والكاميرات
المتنقله والاستوديو حق التصوير الله
وبعدها عندنا الفوال
الفوال والقهوه
احنا في السوق الشعبي هذا السوق الشعبي
مكتمل يعني هذه الحياه اللي كانت في
المنطقه الغربيه طبعا في سبعين ثمانين سنه
السوق الشعبي يكون زي كذا اي نعم
المنتجات اللي موجوده في الدكان ويطلع
محمود معانا بشكل سريع على المنتجات
الدكان فيه الحبوب بانواعها في البسكوت في
الحلاوه في الدخان في الصابون في الزيت في
كل شيء خاص
بالبيت وزي مثلا زيت السيارات
البارد الغاز كل شيء
تاريخها ولا والبيض هذه للبيض خلي البيض
عدم استعمالها طيب بنروح لمين
الالعاب الالعاب اي العاب الاطفال قديما
واغلبها خالد
انا ما لحقت عليه
لا خالد خالد خالد خالد
هذه كلها انت عارفها زين
والله ما ادري انا ما اعرف المصاقي في نجد
يسمونه مصاقيل لكن في الغربيه حلو
يقوم باكثر من دوري اللي هو الحلاق الحلاق
والحجامه والتقليع الاضراس
وعنده شنطه متنقله يروح البيوت
متنقل خالد جيت عند المزين
جرب انت وخلينا يعني نجرب فيك وبعدين
بنادق في مصلح البنادق النحاس مو انا اقول
انت جربت قبلي يعني بحكم السن يعني
طبعا النحاس الحداد النجار
احنا بس عشان الوقت يعني ما يداهمنا احنا
عندنا هنا اكثر اكثر من محل السروجي
القطان طبعا الناس اللي شغاله في ذي كلهم
ايدي سعوديه يعني حرفيين وانت جايب كل
الادوات اللي كانوا يستخدمونها في ذاك
الزمن في ذاك الزمن وعندي حرفين يشتغلون
في نفس الشكل الحين بننتقل الى القسم قسم
الترفيه والفن والطرب والسينما ايش اللي
قاعد يصير الان تعال يا محمود هذا الفنان
حجاب الله يرحمه
[موسيقى]
مين اللي يغني
الله الله يرحمه ويغفر له
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه
يعني
سينما روادي تلفزيونات حتى قطع الغيار
حقها كله ايه وجنب الاجهزه الصوتيه مصلح
الساعات
الساعات هذه قديمه جدا قديمه جدا ويصلحها
الخربانه لو ابي اشتري انا منك
عرض طبعا هذا قسم التلفونات هذا سنترال
الملك سعود تمام ايوه هذا سنترال الملك
سعود طبعا اول اتصال اجري مع الملك سعود
رحمه الله عليه والملك فاروق من الحويه من
السنتر احنا بس بناخذكم على اخر قسم اللي
نقدر نصور معاكم اللي هو السيارات
والجماليات اللي موجوده فيها عندنا هنا
الدوريه وعندنا سيارات عطينا بس سريعه
والله سريعه هذي جننتني سريعه لانه الوقت
خالد بيهرب من تاريخه
[موسيقى]
هذه الدوريه زمان لما كانوا يشغلوا
الونانات هذا الونان حقهم كان يشتغل باليد
يا خالد اعتقد انت تذكر تذكر هذا الامر
يعني
[ضحك]
هذه عاد اقدم اقدم سياره موجوده عند
المتحف عمرها
1926 وهي الفور طبعا في كثير وبالهندل في
كثير من الاقسام احنا ما نقدر ناخذكم في
كل المتحف ولكن المتحف غني بالتراث القديم
للمنطقه الغربيه وحسب ما قال لي الاستاذ
علي بانه يعني من سنه الهجريه كم عام هجري
ايش المتحف اكثر من 20 سنه
من الصفر
متحف ولا اجمل جدا شكرا لك على هذه الجوله
الرائعه يا سعود يعطيك العافيه